okay welcome back everybody so this is
the last lecture on complex analysis
which is great
let me think there's a couple of
administrative things we have a box to
turn in homework in the Emme front
office so now like please turn it into
the box and not to me you can also
submit it I think online to the canvas
drop box thing which some of you know
about and the T's will get it
electronically I kind of prefer paper
copies but that's just me I'm not
grading them though so it doesn't really
matter there's no class on Monday it's a
university holiday so don't come to
class on Monday I won't be here I
haven't decided if I'll make up the
lecture with a video recorded lecture or
not so until you hear otherwise there
just won't be any class on Monday I'm
also not sure I want to have a second
homework do one week from today
and I just wanted to gauge interest how
many of you would be crushed if you
didn't have a second homework due next
Friday how many of you be slightly
crushed not a lot just a little it's
okay if we don't have a homework next
Friday okay I think I'm gonna cancel
next Friday's homework and I'll still
keep the homeworks worth like 60 percent
of the grade because there's just not
that much stuff I want to ask you on
this homework and I definitely don't
want to write a homework today alright
so we'll have a bigger homework in two
weeks that'll cover kind of the last
week of complex and also the first week
of PDEs which are starting that's next
week all right are there any questions
or anything administrative since I won't
see you for about five days anything at
all
nothing okay so all that I'm gonna do
today is complex integrals all right we
know how to do Koshi integral formula we
know how to do Co she Gore saw we know
how to do surgery on contours we know
the ML bound and so now I'm just going
to show you a couple of examples of
integrals that are neat that you can do
by hand the most important one the only
one that I actually have to show you
today is the inverse Laplace transform
because we're going to use that more
later and it's a beast it has three
pages so we're gonna do this one time
today but it's kind of interesting like
we're gonna learn a lot and get some
good practice and then I'm just gonna
keep doing complex integrals until the
bell rings and anything I don't get to
will be in my notes online shortly okay
good
so we're going to do the inverse Laplace
transform
and just I've already asked you how many
of you know how to derive these or look
them up from tables but I just want to
kind of crowdsource why do we care at
all about inverse Laplace transforms or
Laplace transforms in general what are
they good for I'm stalling
I don't what do we use the Laplace
transforms for sorry okay so for solving
differential equations why our lip loss
transform is good for solving
differential equations algebraic yeah so
anytime derivative becomes just a power
of my Laplace variable s and so instead
of a nth order differential equation I
get an nth order polynomial which in
principle should be easier to solve
either by hand or numerically so that's
a great one what's another reason we
would solve things using Laplace
transforms maybe let's stick with ODB's
how many control theorists are in the
audience okay so what would you use a
Laplace transform representation for a
differential equation in control theory
I'll transfer function right so if in
the little plus transform takes me from
the time domain into the frequency
domain and so if I have some physical
system like a mass on a spring or a bath
of fluid or a rubber band it will tell
me this transfer function will tell me
what the output of my system will look
like if I give it a pure tone sinusoidal
input okay so the Laplace transform
gives me frequency domain information
which is really really useful we're also
going to find that it's extremely
important when you solve partial
differential equations of parabolic type
so like heat equations where you can
solve the equations forward in time but
you can't solve it backward in time
applause transforms are going to be
super important for that okay
so I give you three big examples because
I have three big pages of math that's
the least I can do so let's write this
down okay so our Laplace transform I'm
not going to the forward Laplace
transform we're going to talk all about
Laplace transforms later so I'm just
going to write down the formula for the
inverse Laplace transform if I have some
function in the frequency domain this
could be my transfer function or it
could be the frequency domain solution
of a PDE this is just some function in
the in terms of a Laplace variable s s
is a complex number then this is defined
as this really funky integral 1 over 2
pi I integral from gamma minus I in
Finity to gamma plus I infinity of my
function e to the S T integrated with
respect to s this is just a definition
triangle above and equal means I'm
making stuff up and there's a few
conditions so time is always positive or
at least non-negative and gamma has to
be greater than the real part of all
poles of my function f poles are just
another fancy word for singularities
they're you know divisions by zero in
the complex plane ok but it's not that
complicated this is what I want if I
want to solve the inverse Laplace
transform and find my time domain
function this is what I have to do I
have to compute this big integral ok so
I'm gonna do a simple example that just
kind of shows how we use Koshi
integral formula and ML bounds and all
the stuff we've learned to actually
solve these inverse Laplace transforms
so a specific example is the inverse
Laplace transform with f of s equals 1
over s minus a ok this is one of the
most frequent frequency domain functions
that we're going to deal with and
systems dynamics control theory all
kinds of linear dynamics end up looking
like this this is also the solution to
the simplest OD e x dot equals a times X
if I took the Laplace transform of this
I would get something like you know
Laplace of X dot is s times X hat and so
that equals a times X hat and so if I
collected all of this stuff I would get
X hat equals 1 over s minus a ok so this
is the transfer function for our
simplest differential equation ever will
go way more into detail on this in a
later time so don't you know worry if
you don't remember what the Laplace
transform of a derivative is we'll go
through that later but this is a really
important transfer function and so I
want to motivate that we can actually do
something useful by taking the inverse
Laplace transform so I want to know what
is the solution in time for this
transfer function so I have two inverse
Laplace transform this okay
we know the solution in time is you know
X of T equals e to the a T X naught but
I want to be able to get that using my
inverse Laplace transform function ok
because it's not going to be it's not
always true that my function is so
simple that I know it's solution in the
time domain anyway ok so this thing that
we're trying to solve is d
okay so what I want is the Laplace
transform inverse the inverse Laplace
transform of 1 over 1 minus 1 divided by
s minus a is this thing and I'm gonna
plug 1 over s minus a into F hat so this
is my big integral gamma minus I
infinity gamma plus I infinity of e to
the S T divided by s minus a D s what is
this starting to look like looks like a
analytic function with a pole that I've
inserted at a right so this looks a lot
like I can apply Koshi integral viola ok
so this is what we want to solve and I'm
going to draw this contour in the
complex plane and get some kind of
geometric feeling for what we're
actually doing so this is my complex
plane and it doesn't matter where my
pole is in the complex plane let's say
it's a positive pole so this is an
unstable differential equation then my
dynamics sorry my contour here is going
to be a contour in the vertical
direction at some real valued location
that's to the right of my pole right
gamma has to be greater than the real
part of my pole so I'm going to draw
this contour here go in kind of up
forever and that's what I want I want
this big integral over this red line ok
now what's a way that I can use Koshi
integral formula for a pole here and
some integral with a big vertical
segment
sorry yes I could try to close this loop
somehow okay
and the way I'm going to close it this
is kind of the classical way that most
people do it cause it's the simplest way
is I'm going to add these positive and
negative segments here I'm going to call
this C + + C - and then I'm gonna have a
big radius which I'm going to call C R
okay so let's just do a little bit of
definition so this is a big circle of
radius R these points here are gamma
plus IR and gamma minus IR okay and the
integral that I want is the vertical
segment of this as I take the limit for
R goes to infinity right if I take this
shape this geometric D shape and I blow
it up to R equals infinity then this
vertical integral portion is my inverse
Laplace transform okay good so what is
this big
so this shape this D shape is called
Bromwich integral
okay not to be confused with the
broodwich
integral maybe you know what the
broodwich is most evil sandwich ever
made we harvested from hell's half-acre
mayonnaise made from the eggs of
deranged chickens he'd never heard of
the broodwich yeah all right so this is
the Bromwich integral okay and let's
take a step back what do we know about
the integral of this function over this
contour for any R sorry we can apply
Koshi integral formula which would be 2
pi i times my analytic function
evaluated at my pole right my pole here
it so this big integral let's say 1 over
2 pi i times my big contour integral
this whole Bromwich integral of e to the
S T over s minus a D s is equal to ok
well it's equal to the integral I want
sorry let me say that the limit as R
goes to infinity of this thing is the
integral I want the inverse Laplace
transform of 1 over s minus a plus the
integral around C plus plus the integral
around C minus plus the integral around
C at radius R right the big contour
integral is equal to the thing I want
Plus this segment plus this segment Plus
this segment and this whole thing all
four of these integrals add up to what
you just said which is I take Koshi
integral formula and I get 2 pi e to the
80 divided by 2 pi
this whole thing equals e to the AAT
okay any questions about that I do the
last step a little fast so maybe if
there's questions this would be a good
time to ask that makes sense we had this
integral we want and I have no idea how
to solve it
you know using classical calculus
methods so I cooked up some big contour
integral around my single simple pole I
know what that integral equals because
of Cauchy integral formula and so then I
can argue that that Koshi integral
portion which is e to the a T is equal
to the thing I want plus the other three
segments and what I'm going to argue is
that as R goes to infinity these three
segments go to zero so we need to show
we need these to go to 0 as R goes to
infinity that's what I'm going to spend
the next like 15 minutes doing is
showing that each of these terms goes to
0 as R goes to infinity and if that's
true then my Laplace transform my
inverse Laplace transform is just e to
the 8e right inverse Laplace transform
plus 0 plus 0 plus 0 equals e to the I T
which is what we know it has to equal
from basic differential equations ok no
questions
this is like the important time to ask
questions because we're going to go
deeper yeah this one right here yes so
this vertical line is like my starting
point you know in those books where you
like it teaches you how to draw animals
and you start with like one big line and
then you add the ears and the eyes and
everything like this is the thing that I
started with this vertical line is the
thing I care about if I take the limit
as R goes to infinity this vertical line
is the integral that I want my inverse
Laplace transform so I'm starting with
that vertical
and I'm just trying to make any way
possible in the complex plane
to figure out what that vertical line
equals yeah okay
there's an interesting question related
to that I hope this isn't confusing but
let's say that I had my Pole and I have
my word line so I told you that it's
useful to construct this contour here
this Bromwich integral why didn't they
construct a contour going this way sorry
both of you said something you said
because it equals 0 so this contour
really cool 0 why no pole inside the
function is analytic and you said yeah
so there's no pole inside so this
integral is equal to 0 but that just
means that this big positive contour
integral equals this vertical contour
integral negative and it doesn't really
help us like we don't know any more than
we did before so I'm just trying to
think kind of rationally so we really
want to be enclosing this pole because
it says something very specific about
this integral and I can actually argue
that these parts are negative why do you
think I can argue that this big contour
is negative
sorry not negative I mean 0 why is this
go to 0 as R goes to infinity
and why does this not this is the crux
of my entire argument so I figure we
should just start there so that would be
a really good idea I tried it it didn't
work why why do you think that the ml
bound might work on this though because
this length is infinite it's pi r and r
is going to infinity so why would this
why would the function times L why would
M times L still go to 0 so this isn't
true for any function that I've been
hurting this is true for LaPlante
inverse Laplace transforms and they have
this e to the St okay so I basically
have something like you know e to the S
T over s minus a and what does e to the
S T look like for positive and negative
real parts of s yes so if the real part
of s if s is positive real part that
blows up it's huge if s has a negative
real part this is really small and if I
take R goes to infinity it has a really
really negative real part most of the
time okay so that's the basic idea this
contour we can expect to be relatively
small because this thing just gets small
for negative real part s and T is always
positive and if I had positive real part
s everything would blow up so this is
not equal to 0 it's like a nasty
positive integral that's the intuition
behind what we're doing ok I'm gonna
erase this
okay so I told you you couldn't use ml
balance for the big radial portion but
you can certainly use it for C+ and see
- because the L never changes the length
of these is always gamma so it's always
small and I claim that my you know
function parts going to get smaller it's
going to go to zero okay good so let's
do this okay so we're gonna solve the C
plus and the C minus parts using ml
bound okay and I just told you the
length never changes so for c + + c - we
have you know they're just gamma long L
never changes L is always equal to gamma
this is just a number
okay so this is true regardless our
going to infinity okay so we're gonna
take this let's just do integral of C +
of e to the S T divided by s minus a yes
okay so what do I need to do to this
function to apply ml bound
I basically need to show that this
function goes to zero on that curve
alright and you just showed that this
function is bounded by another function
that goes to 0 as R goes to infinity ok
so I'm going to this actually is a easy
integral for me to write out you know
usually I write these contours C and
that's a way of me avoiding actually
using coordinates but I can actually
write this out in coordinates because
it's just moving along the real axis
direction so this is the integral from
gamma plus IR to IR so gamma plus IR -
IR of e to the S T over s minus a D s
and that is the same as integrating just
in DX from gamma to 0 so I'm integrating
from gamma to zero in DX and what I'm
integrating is e to the X plus IR T
divided by X plus IR minus a I just
plugged in s equals x plus IR on C plus
write on this curve my complex variable
s is restricted to be some real part
plus IR the imaginary parts always IR ok
so I can take my contour integral sorry
just my line integral and I can
literally write it as a line integral in
DX I say anything wrong
like please shout interrupt
okay
and this thing is going to be less than
or equal to ml and so we need so
basically I want to take this function
and bound it okay now how do we do that
so n is going to be the maximum of this
function for X between 0 and gamma so
it's the maps over all x between 0 and
gamma of this function X sorry each of
the X plus IR T divided by X plus IR
minus a absolute value because I don't
care if it's positive negative or has
some complex phase angle del carril so n
is going to be the maximum of this
function over the entire possible range
of X from 0 to gamma and I'm going to
show that this has to go to 0 as R goes
to infinity the maximum absolute value
of this this this function shrinks to 0
as R goes to infinity that's what we're
showing okay and so this thing is less
than or equal to actually pretty sure
it's just equal to e to the gamma T over
R so the worst case numerator I can
possibly build the biggest numerator is
X has X equal to positive gamma
right like e to the 2 is bigger than e
to the 0 so either the positive gamma is
going to be bigger than either this 0 so
I'm plugging in gamma for X is gonna how
to make the biggest numerator and
similarly the smallest denominator
because when X is equal to a then this
would be R so this thing is at least
less than or equal to this you can
convince yourself that this is true
gamma and T are positive gamma is a
constant so this goes to 0 as R goes to
infinity I didn't convince you terribly
compellingly how to go from here to here
but it's not that complicated like each
of the real part plus imaginary parts
its magnitude is never going to be
larger than e to the gamma T that's the
biggest this thing's real part can ever
be is e to the gamma T this bottom part
looks a lot like 1 over R and as R gets
huge this R is gonna dwarf either of
these two terms it doesn't really matter
when I plug in there this thing is
basically never going to be bigger than
e to the gamma T divided by R ok that
goes to 0 as R goes to infinity and so I
have M times L equals 0 and so this C
plus integral has to be equal to 0 so
the integral of C plus equals 0
similarly integral of C minus equals 0
it's the exact same thing but with a
couple of minus signs ok are there some
questions about what went on here does
this still bother people feel like this
is bothering everyone myself included
okay yeah sorry I skipped a lot of steps
so e to the X plus IR T equals e to the
X T e to the IR T T is a positive number
it's time right it's not complex it's
not negative it's positive real number
time so this is the real part the real
part this is the imaginary part and so
this equals e to the X T times cos I or
T plus I sine R T okay now the length of
this thing the magnitude the radius of
this complex number is this this is the
magnitude this is just the face this can
never increase or decrease my magnitude
okay so the length of this thing the raw
like length or size of this function is
given by e to the X T okay
and how do I make either the X T bigger
for positive X between 0 and gamma I
used the biggest possible value of x on
my range which is gamma so e to the
gamma T is the largest this is ever
going to be e to the 0 t is just you
know radius 1 that's the smallest it's
ever going to be so this function is
largest as the biggest numerator e to
the gamma T when X is equal to gamma so
sorry I skipped like two equal signs
that's bad I can skip one equal sign but
not two does that make sense now and the
dude the denominator this part always
confuses me but basically X is not going
to be bigger than gamma a is definitely
smaller than gamma and R is going to
infinity so this thing is divided by
infinity okay alright so C plus and C
minus R 0 but that was unfortunately the
easy part
as I told you the C R curve you can't
actually use ml bound on this you have
to use something that's slightly better
the ml downs it's called the Jordan
Lenna
which means it's harder than the ml
bound because some guy's name is on it
they don't put your name on things
I guess they put boilers name on this
that was pretty simple oh yeah so great
question so why didn't I just have a big
circle here like that that's just a much
much much harder integral like this
function is weird it's it's it's Z minus
gamma equals R e to the I theta and it's
just a lot harder to solve like this is
a nice constant radius with respect to
the origin zero but this - curve is not
it's a it's like a weird function with
respect to the coordinate system we're
in which is centered at zero it's still
it's still a pain try it up try to try
to evaluate try to evaluate this
integral and it'll be almost impossible
because you won't be able to use the
Jordan lemma we're gonna rely on the
fact that this entire curve has negative
real part okay but this - semicircle
does not have its entire curve have a
negative real part it has these parts
here and so that's why I like to kind of
solve them separately using ml bound
even though they're finite and positive
they're you know kind of the length is
finite and positive that term goes to 0
as R goes to infinity so I handle those
separately this is really the right way
to do it if you try to do it a different
way it becomes harder believe it or not
okay does everyone feel ok but yeah is
there a reason basically
see - I can deal with Epsilon's balls
okay it's a good question so this this
one is c-plus
let's see if we can write down see -
it's not necess to me that see - is
actually - of C + they both equal zero
so obviously they are you know equal and
opposite and the same all all at once
but it's not clear to me that that
negative curve actually cancels this out
so how would we write that out so C - is
the integral from zero to gamma because
we're going from left to right of the
same exact function except now I have e
to the X minus IR T because I'm at minus
I R divided by X minus IR - a D X so
this is C - it's a really good question
I never thought about this before and
this definitely equals negative zero but
let's say that I didn't take the limit
as R goes to infinity
like can I actually cancel these out for
finite ours I'm almost sure you can't
because I'm pretty sure that this thing
does not equal zero and so these have to
add up to something that cancels that
out so I'm pretty sure that they don't
cancel I'm just trying to show it easily
so the way you would do this this is
essentially some complex number e to the
X minus IR T divided by some real part X
minus a minus IR and what I would do is
I'd multiply top and bottom by a complex
conjugate transpose so I had just a
complex function divided by a real
number and I would do that to this
function and to this function and I'm
pretty sure you can show that they don't
cancel out so that's a like that's how
you would do it I don't I think it would
take a long time to actually show that
they don't cancel but I'm pretty
uncertain they don't cancel because I
know that this curve is not equal to
zero until I take art to infinity and so
these components have to add up to
something finite the cancels
no they might equal they might cancel I
don't know you like try it out tell me
if they cancel or not I don't think they
do or else I just wasted a lot of your
time okay so the last one that we need
to solve is integral of CR and this
integral is a little harder so you can
try to do the ML bound and you'll find
that you run into a problem the ML bound
is not it's just an upper bound it's not
the tightest bound possible so it
doesn't always work there's lots of
cases where the function really does go
to 0 the integral does go to 0 but the
ml bound doesn't prove it funny ok it's
just an upper bound and so alright the
best way to do this is just a jump end
so now we're going to do the integral of
the big radius portion we're going to
take that radius to infinity and so ml
doesn't work and so we're gonna try
polar coordinates now if I had all the
time of the world I'd show you that ml
bound doesn't work but you can try it
out and if we just tried to do ml bound
we run into an obstacle it wouldn't work
ok so we're going to try polar
coordinates we're gonna say x equals
minus our coasts theta and y equals R
sine of theta and we're gonna draw this
picture where our red curve here our red
curve is like this
and my coordinate system theta this is a
little different than what we normally
we normally defined theta from the
positive real here I'm defining theta
from the negative real just because it
makes my math easier you can do it from
positive real you just get a much more
negative some weird stuff happening so
I'm counting kind of up from negative
one okay so I'm gonna take my my
integral and I'm gonna take the
numerator and the denominator and I'm
gonna try to get as tight to the bound
as I possibly can on both of those terms
on this red curve here so first I'm
going to take each of the st and the
absolute value of that is going to be
the real part of s times T so that's
equal to e to the minus R T Coast's
theta if I use these coordinates right
this is just the real part XT this is
what we wrote down when I skipped all of
those steps this is you know the norm
the length of this e to the S T is given
by e to the X T and I'm using these
coordinates for X pretty straightforward
okay and now I need a bound for s minus
a the denominator and this is kind of a
tricky one so I'm going to plug in my
coordinates here so I have minus our
coasts theta for the real parts minus a
this is my real part and then I'm also
gonna have plus I times R sine theta it
literally just took my polar coordinate
representation I plugged it into s minus
a and I'm writing down the real and the
imaginary part okay
so the length of this now I'm just going
to use Pythagorean theorem the length of
this is the square root of this squared
plus this squared okay so that's what
our cows theta plus a
a squared plus R squared sine theta
squared square roots I'm gonna skip you
can expand this out collect terms solve
for some stuff and basically what you
can find this is you know R squared plus
2a Arcos beta plus a squared and that's
bigger than or equal to the length of
our minus a this is the length of our
it's going to be really really terribly
boring if I try to prove to you why this
is true but you can draw a picture like
just draw a picture in polar coordinates
of s minus a and you can convince
yourself that it really is larger than
this at this step okay okay good so I
have a bound on the numerator well I
actually know exactly what the length of
the numerator is and I have a bound on
the denominator my denominator is larger
than that
in magnitude okay so we have our contour
integral of e to the S T divided by s
minus a D s is less than or equal to
integral minus PI over 2 to PI over 2 I
should tell you that this is PI over 2
and this is theta equals minus PI over 2
right in this coordinate system positive
PI over 2 negative PI over 2 for theta
so I'm integrating from theta equals
negative PI over 2 to PI over 2 of this
thing divided by this thing that's e to
the minus R T Co stata divided by R
minus a norm and I'm integrating that in
polar coordinates so I get an Rd theta
okay and I'm integrating this purely
with respect to theta because my R is
constant so I'm going to pop all the our
stuff out so this equals R divided by
norm of R minus a times integral minus
PI over 2 to PI over 2 e to minus RT
Coast's theta D theta okay we're almost
almost done except I don't know how to
integrate this does anyone know how to
integrate this there's one more trick
it's terrible because I don't know how
to integrate this I just don't have I'd
have to do another terrible contour
integral probably so what we're gonna
use is we're going to use a final trick
so kind of final trick is that Coase of
theta is always greater than or equal to
1 minus 2 theta divided by PI on the
interval 0 to PI over 2 I don't know why
this is true I found this on the
Internet this is true cosa theta is
always bigger than this you could prove
this if you want it to but just this is
a trick this is the last trick I'm going
to use okay you have to use
unfortunately a lot of these things for
really hard integrals so I'm basically
going to take this integral and I'm
going to say that it's less than or
equal to sorry it's greater than or
equal to I'm just gonna plug in 1 minus
2 theta over PI for cosa theta okay so
okay so my complex contour integral
around this curve C R is less than or
equal to R over R minus a magnitude
integral minus PI over 2 to PI over 2 of
e to the R t2 theta over PI minus 1
and I can actually integrate this thing
with respect to theta okay so that
equals R over R minus a so if I
integrate this with respect to theta
then I have some big constant to our T
over pi
that's my constant so I get times 1 over
2 R T over pi or maybe my PI can go up
here each of the are T 2 theta over PI
minus 1 evaluated at minus PI over 2 to
PI over 2 ok this thing ends up being
something like
sorry this is bad okay so you can go
through all of this and you find that
what you end up getting is this R and
this R cancel
we have PI over magnitude of R minus a
times T and this thing evaluates out to
one minus e to the minus R T it's a lot
of calculus this isn't a calculus class
so this thing evaluates out to this and
I cancel out my two and finally we see
that this term as R goes to infinity you
know this looks like 1 as R goes to
infinity this term looks like 1 over R
as R goes to infinity so this whole
thing equals 0 as R goes to infinity
okay now this is a terrible algebraic
and calculus based proof you have to do
all this messy garbage to actually show
that it's equal to zero but the basic
intuition is that on this portion of the
curve the real part of e to the S T is
always the real part of s T is always
negative so e to the S T is small and as
I make this radius larger e to the S T
gets smaller a lot smaller and then gets
smaller faster than this length so this
is basically like a fancy refined
version of the ML bound ok we still used
a bunch of like poundings of the
numerator and the denominator and all of
this stuff to show that this is equal to
0 ok I want to leave that board so what
we've done is we've taken our inverse
Laplace transform which is this big
single segment infinite length integral
we've connected this around the single
simple pole at s equals a to use Koshi
integral formula
so we know that that whole thing equals
e to the eighty and then we showed that
all other segments except for the one we
care about all integrate to zero as my
radius goes to infinity okay I was a lot
of work that took the entire class just
to get to the fact that my inverse
Laplace transform of probably the
simplest transfer function ever equals e
to the 18th the solution of the simplest
differential equation ever okay so I'm
not recommending that you actually use
contour integrals to solve these
problems and not use a lookup table but
you really really really should know
that you actually can do these things by
hand if you have to and when you plug
this into Mathematica it's actually
doing all of these tricks like in its
computer brain very very quickly but it
knows all of these tricks and it's
applying them that's actually how it's
solving these things it's using Koshi
integral formula okay that's all that I
want to tell you that's all that I have
time to tell you in the course notes
which I'm going to upload sometime early
this afternoon there are two other
examples of complex integrals and I just
want you to look them over and get a
feeling for them because they are the
kinds of things I would ask on midterms
or finals or claws so there's two extra
contour integrals in my notes they are
fair game you might as well consider
that like the makeup lecture for Monday
okay
that's all have a great weekend I'll see
you on Wednesday